the jurgen experience
well you know one of the interesting
things about endogenous dmt and
especially with this discovery in such
high levels in the brain is that it may
be the endomatrix it could be kind of
regulating everything all of the time
what do you mean by that regulating
everything all the time it could be the
way we interact with reality
is through endogenous dmt which is
always at a steady level
well
it's
the way i began wondering about that is
because you know what is the purpose of
endogenous dmt
you know why does the brain make dmt can
you do a dmt test on a person's blood
level
it's pretty hard it's pretty hard it's
really low in the blood it's like you
know billionths of a gram per milliliter
okay so you'd have to measure it in the
actual brain itself in the brain or
spinal fluid maybe spinal fluid but most
likely brain when they start doing stuff
like neural link where they're going to
insert wires into your brain
and you know you're going to have an app
to control your brain to control your
mood i mean it seems like that would be
one of the ways they would do it right
um
well you'd need to find you know where
in the brain the main
source of dmt is and then put an
electrode there and keep that going do
you think it's con it's limited to one
specific area where it's developed
oh man they're just they're just
beginning to
unravel the whole
uh
role and location of endogenous dmt so
when they know that it's in the liver
and they know that it's in the lungs um
the lungs to me sound interesting
because of holotropic breathing right
you know because people have done
breathing exercises and achieved states
of
altered states of consciousness
yeah yeah it kind of makes sense doesn't
it
well yeah but i think it's not working
through the lungs because those more
recent studies haven't really
demonstrated dmt and lung oh yeah yeah i
used to say it's made in lung everybody
used to say it's made in lung but it
seems like it's made in brain so if it's
made in brain then all the other stuff
you're just getting like a trickle-down
effect
well does it go through the whole body
yeah but it's metabolized so quickly
that you know by the time it gets into
the blood that you're drawing the
concentrations are pretty minuscule wow
what a sneaky molecule
well you have to wonder what it's doing
right right what is it doing what is
endogenous what's the function of it you
know there's the possibility we have a
dmt neurotransmitter system like
serotonin or dopamine in which case you
know what is it doing
wow so this is this is a really wild way
to think about it because to this time
i've never even considered that i always
thought of it as being something that
was responsible maybe for very vivid
dreams
or something that was responsible for
near-death experiences or what happens
to when you die the idea of a portal but
i never thought about it as being
something that is regulating
regular everyday reality
um
well
you know one of the hallmarks of the dmt
effect
is that it feels more real than real
yeah
and uh
you study the function of endogenous
neurotransmitters by giving you know
drugs that modify the effect of that
endogenous neurotransmitter
you know so
we've got the ssr antidepressants and
they affect serotonin although they may
not all that much but but still that's
been the working model for decades
and uh
you know so you know because sris are
useful for depression and anxiety
you then can speculate that serotonin is
responsible for mood or anxiety
you know so the hallmark of the you know
dmt effect is it's more real than real
it feels more real than anything else
you know so it's tempting to speculate
but again when i go back to that
disembodied
mind thought process of like thinking
like what am i thinking when i'm over
there since my body doesn't seem to be
there and i'm there and it's it seems
more real than real is that me
just tricking myself into thinking that
it's a different place
uh
i mean how could you tell how could i
tell right yeah i mean how would you
know i have one way of looking at that i
always describe this is what i say to
people i say
if there was a thing that you could do
like a door you could go through and
that door would take you
to the another dimension where you would
communicate with
some entity
beyond
your wildest imagination that's
constantly visually changing and
communicating with you
telepathically
and knows everything about you sees all
your [ __ ]
and is trying to impart some ideas that
will help you with your life
because it's a god-like experience like
you're experiencing like some sort of uh
uber-powerful entity some more uber
intelligent entity something beyond any
if we just looked at humans and thought
of the evolution of human one day we'll
get to this we're not going to get to
that
that is a different it seems like it's
so beyond the body it's so beyond the
human monkey body this is what i tell
people i go if i could give if you would
open a door and you would go there and
you'd have that experience
you would you do it and most people like
yes i would do it if i gave you a drug
that gave you that experience you still
have the exact same experience it's the
exact same experience you've just
decided it's not real and you've decided
it's not real because you're putting
into this category of hallucination like
what does that even mean
what does that even mean you're actually
having that experience i don't know what
it is
i mean i i like to play play devil's
advocate and i like to think that maybe
i'm messing with my own head and maybe
i'm just like it's like
well through doing what looking at it
like maybe it's just my neurochemistry
going bonkers and and you know
interacting with my visual cortex could
produce hallucinations
but it doesn't feel that way that's what
i'm that's why i'm trying to figure out
if you're bullshitting yourself when
you're over there
or if it's you really are over there but
what i tell people is it's the same
experience yeah what difference does it
make what yeah yeah
um it's you know previously invisible
yeah and it contains information a lot
yeah and i think that's all you can say
about it
it contains information about you right
well it it could only be happening to
you yeah yeah it's not happening to
somebody else it's like it gives you
advice
it can
uh but you i mean how do you judge the
value of that advice yeah well what is
the one one of the things that happened
to me i've talked about this ad nauseam
unfortunately if you've heard this
before folks but uh
one of my experiences there was like
a bunch of jokers like jesters or like
jester hats and they were giving me the
finger they were going like this [ __ ]
you
and it made me realize i was taking
myself too seriously
like instantaneously i went oh i get it
and they were like this
they went like don't do that don't do
that
but like
saying [ __ ] you to me it was so clear
what they were doing it was so clear it
was like a little lesson like don't do
that
yeah it's interesting you know don't do
that that's like three syllables and
they correspond to a heartbeat you know
when i tripped on dmt the first time
these beings came out of this waterfall
and they said now do you see now you see
how do you see it was the same
three-beat thing
i love you they say i love you a lot i
love you and i think it corresponds to
the heartbeat because it's in sync
you know the localization is in sync
with the heartbeat i love him yeah
the one time i did it and these entities
were talking to me and saying i love you
600 million 500 000 times like the way a
child would say i love you with like
some crazy number
seven billion zillions you know and
every time they did that it would show a
more beautiful image like every image
like i love you six hundred million five
hundred thousand times
i love you seven hundred zillion four
hundred and every time they did it was
just this bigger and bigger experience
visually to the point where i was like
crying i was like openly weeping oh yeah
it's a beauty it's just what i was
seeing it sounds beautiful it was wild
but it was that simple sort of there's
like a like they'll say simple things to
you in a way that
you're not really hearing it
but you know what they're saying well it
kind of penetrates you yeah yeah it's
very weird
and
it's very weird very weird yeah you used
to not talk about your personal
experiences with it i know i figured to
hell with it
yeah i think so
i think it's good that you did that
because i remember when we first met you
were reluctant to discuss it you you i
mean you didn't really want to talk
about it publicly or want people to know
about it publicly
yeah i figured that i had some
legitimacy to maintain
[Laughter]
a few years back i had this conversation
uh you know with dennis mckenna
you know like about your reputation and
or you know one's reputation he said
i've just given up on my reputation it's
just you know so well you talk as openly
about psychedelics as dennis he's the
best guy to talk about it too
because his
he's got a really interesting way of
just discussing things you know and he's
had so many personal experiences and
he's so smart and he's got this
incredible vocabulary to just draw from
and when he describes the actual impact
of psilocybin and psychedelic chemicals
particularly in formation of language he
was describing the stoned ape theory
it's incredible he listened to him say
it because the way he describes it like
he actually understands what psilocybin
and what all these various molecules are
doing to different parts of the brain
and why that would facilitate the
development of language and compassion
and connect the tribe more
well i mean
do you think it actually
is information coming from the brain
or do you think you know that the portal
is being opened up and the information's
coming from above
i think that's more likely i think the
more likely is that the brain is an
antenna
you know it's one of the things that
creative people will always tell you
like someone sits down and writes a song
it just like came from the air they're
getting things from somewhere else
almost it's almost like you just gotta
get out of your own way
you gotta put enough good
juice out there in the world and take
enough bad out and like and then just
and see the world from a a clear
perspective in at least in in these
brief moments of creativity and then
things come to them they just
like they're sitting in front of the
computer and bam they got an idea for a
book like where the [ __ ] is all that
coming from it seems like
people always want to say it's a muse
like that's the stephen pressfield uh
analogy he's got a great book about it
called the war of art all about like
like inviting the muse into your life
and being disciplined and sitting there
at a computer every day and summoning it
and treating it like it's an entity and
if you do that it works like this is
what's crazy like people who are
disciplined and also creative like that
decide i'm going to write this book i'm
going to sit down and i'm going to force
myself every day like ideas come to them
like where they where the [ __ ] are they
coming from like is it possible that the
brain really is like some sort of an
antenna
and that wisdom and love and all these
different things they're just all around
us we're just confused by our monkey
bodies
well do you think we're getting that
information from god if that's what you
want to call it
you know the the the only problem i have
with the word god and it's not really a
problem but
it's a recognition is that it's a loaded
word it's a loaded word but so is love
yes you know so i think you just got to
take the good with the bad well that's
alex gray's position alex gray says we
have to take it back the same way we
take back love and say god all the time
and you know that's what he does yeah
and that's the reason i think it's good
to use the word psychedelic instead of
hallucinogen or yeah i think so too and
theogen or anything and theogen's a cool
word it's cool it assumes a lot though
yeah it's like people that call weed
cannabis yeah i like to smoke a lot of
cannabis like okay settle down buddy
yeah like the term in theogen it refers
to god yeah theos and it refers to n
which means that god exists within
and
it has the word gen in it which means
it's a drug which is generating
something like a like god
you know so that assumes a lot and there
are people who could benefit from
psychedelic experiences who might not
caught into those ideas and would avoid
and theogen but might take a psychedelic
yeah i think psychedelic sounds
manageable and theogen sounds like you
join in a cult
it's a bit cultish
well isn't everything a bit cultish it
seems like whatever anything
you know really affects people in a lot
of ways there's always someone
who looks to sort of take the reins and
sort of dictate what the experience is
and how to do it and what the ritual
should be and how you should you know
manage it and it gets culty uh it gets
culty um but i think you could you know
decalcify it yes you know to some extent